si l'été ne chante plus en toi plus rien
ne chante en toi et si plus rien ne
chante en toi tu ne peux plus faire de
musique
elle m'a dit ça une
fois bonsoir Je m'appelle Len bonsoir
féici c'est une vraie beauté parle-moi
d'elle elle est merveilleuse et adorable
à l'époque à laquelle on vit chacun peut
se sentir
mal- ça je sais exactement qui tu
[Musique]
es il pourrait devenir le premier grand
chef d'orchestre
américain il y a un prix à payer pour
graviter dans l'orbite de mon frère tu
le
sais
[Musique]
j'aime tellement les gens que pour moi
il est difficile d'être
seul et j'aime la musique elle me
maintient en
vie
tu ne te doutes pas à quel point tu as
besoin de
moi peutêtre bien
que mais si l'été ne chante plus en toi
plus rien ne chante en
[Musique]
toi et si plus rien ne chante en toi tu
ne peux plus faire de
musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]